I took the team to Borneo on ask out of
camp leakey and normally to go upriver
to this jungle camp where orangutans
live it's a four-hour ride by these
large wooden river boats though we
didn't have that much time so we rented
these two very small speedboats that got
us up the river in about 90 minutes so
we went and we visit camp leakey and you
know we see all these incredible
orangutans xin the forest and you know
we start you know putting together the
blueprint for the film and we come back
to the dock and our boats are gone just
totally gone and you know we look up
river and we can see in a Ranga tan
inside one of the boats paddling it up
river all by himself and he had what he
had done is while we were gone he came
down to the dock and he untied both
boats and he sent one downriver and he
climbed in the other one and he
commandeered it you know to the other
side of the river and he's pulling
himself along along the reeds and
paddling and we were stuck there
stranded it was just one of those
moments where we all stood on the dock
looking at each other just thinking
alright this is going to be a great
movie we never saw him again but he's
actually the offspring of a very famous
orangutan named princess who was taught
sign language in the 70s and princess
was a famous boat thief in her day and
there are actually some photographs of
her paddling a little wooden canoe on
the river back in the 70s and so this is
a skill that she's been teaching her
kids for the last 30 years you know you
see a boat steal it boats are fun this
is what you do when orangutan steals
your boat you question your place in the
universe you think yeah we're not
necessarily number one around here